[Music]
i've been thinking about this a lot
about
what would i do if this was my last day
on earth
and i would show up in
and actually witness it
see it for what it is yeah without being
blinded by the past yeah without being
blinded by the future i'm reminded of
one of my favorite books
has a book called angels by dennis
johnson mahalik i'm sure you've read
angels at some point no it's one of my
favorites so i'm going to run it for you
i apologize the climax of the by the way
fast forward two minutes if you don't
want to hear this the climax of the
novel main character's name is bill
houston this is we haven't read it since
i was in my 20s but it just stuck with
me it was so powerful
it's
his last day on earth he's been
convicted of murder
and he's going to the electric chair
and they're walking him to the electric
chair
and he recognized how unfair this moment
is
because everything he actually sees now
whether it's the blue the bluest blue
he's ever seen in the sky
out the little tiny
barred window or he sees a bird fly
overhead or the mountains in the
colorado distance yeah and he sees them
actually sees them
for the first time
and
he's not thinking about where he's going
to be tomorrow because he won't be here
tomorrow yeah he's finally living
his life like it's his last day not
because he's striving or hedonistic
but he's seeing everything around him
and the reason i brought this up ryan is
out when i moved recently i was
beginning to lament
the
condo that i was moving out of we were
living in west hollywood a really
nice condo it was
real simple
and i enjoyed living there a lot
but i took a lot of it for granted like
we take everything for granted like yeah
simple things like the exit sign
or the signage out front we don't see it
we tune it out
we label it and dismiss it
so that we
can ruminate on achievements or needing
more whatever it might be
and instead i as i was
spending my last week there it was like
i was on a
sort of death row of sorts
because that part of my life was dying
mm-hmm
no longer was i going to see the same
things again end of the chapter man and
it allowed me to see them yeah
in a way that i wouldn't have otherwise
seen them but we can do that right now
we can see
the simplicity that's all around us yeah
the door handle the bird the child
laughing the dog barking in the
background whatever it is we can see it
right now that's what it means to live
every day like it's your last even if
you had like a list of 100 things i mean
you couldn't do a hundred things so it's
like the more you desire
to do on your last day like you almost
like for me i would just see the things
i didn't get to do
you know if that's my attitude was like
just trying to be as hedonistic as
possible like and that was that bucket
list thing we talked about earlier in
the private podcast
yeah if i fulfill the bucket list
even if you had one year left to live
right yeah
it's never going to be enough when it
becomes hedonistic right not that
there's anything wrong with pleasure but
that pursuit of pleasure is not actually
living in the moment it's craving some
future outcome it's funny because mariah
and i
we
the the apartment we live in now it was
kind of like the best of the options
that we had there's a funny thing in la
it's like you have this you have this um
lease
and if you want to move you can't find a
place too early because then you got
like double payments double rent
payments
you can't find a place too late because
you got to be out by a certain time so
like we ended up getting this place that
i'm really happy with
and i have always like if when we moved
in there i'm like this is temporary like
i don't really want to like be here this
is just kind of like with you know given
the resources and the things that we
have like this is where we're at and
we're going to move and like we've been
looking at moving lately and it's funny
because when i think about leaving the
place we're at now i'm like wait a
minute like there's like a beauty to
this place like there's a beautiful
community and like it's got this like
really cool like you know really like
like 50s modern feel if that makes it's
not art deco but i mean there's just
like a cool
vibe to it that like when i think about
leaving and i'm like i actually don't
want to leave this place like i really
like it you're appreciating it now i'm
seeing it for what it is yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free